I just got the feedback from
the one minute things just a few
minutes
before class,
so I think I may defer
commenting on the couple of them
until the beginning of next
lecture.
But there are a couple of
things
that I think I can say.
One is, several people were
wondering, how
does the cell decide whether to
do mitosis or meiosis?
But the
mitosis, which is ordinary cell
division is what happens
everywhere
in your body,
in your intestine,
on your skin,
in your eye,
anywhere
except, since thats how you
make all the different cells you
have.
The meiosis,
which creates the sex sells,
or gametes, happens in a very
specific place,
either in the testes if you are
male or the ovary if you
are a female.
So, there's a dedicated place
where meiosis takes
place, and just your knowledge
of human anatomy and physiology
can
make a pretty good guess as to
where that is.
Everywhere
else, it's mitosis.
There's a very special place
where
that happens.
A couple of you still got
confused when I was talking
about meiosis and I was showing
you a progression through,
and I put a
double headed arrow,
meaning that's what that period
was called.
The process is unidirectional.
It only goes in one way.
It's not a
reversible process.
There were some questions about
the
chiasmata or the chiasma:
why is there a crossover in
chiasma in
meiosis but not mitosis?
I will tell you about that
today very
specifically.
Why was there a tall and a
short pair of chromosomes?
That was arbitrary.
I made up a simple cell for us
to consider these
properties in,
one with a long,
and what with a short,
nothing else.
I
wasn't trying to represent any
particular organism.
And I'll pick up on a couple of
other things.
I just want to
quickly mention something.
Since I've seen you,
I flew out to San
Diego, gave a talk yesterday
morning at a major meeting,
hopped on a
plane, got back at midnight,
and here I am again.
As part of being a
scientist, come teacher,
at a place like MIT,
you guys tend not to see,
but my research life goes on
while I'm teaching.
And I just want to briefly
mention one thing I talked about
yesterday,
because just in my own life it
captures a couple of things that
I've been trying to tell you,
that the textbook is not the
ultimate
authority.
That's just what we think up
until today.
A new finding
to change the way you think
about things,
and what I'm telling you,
and some of your frustrated at,
that I'm not just parroting
back the
textbook is because this is the
way it is.
If you guys are going to be
leaders in whatever field
you're in, you're going to be
dealing with this
process of shifting sands as we
gain new knowledge.
So, in fact what I was talking
about has some relationship to
the cell
cycle that I talked about.
Lee Hartwell particularly
helped us
understand that there is what's
called a G1 phase,
which you could
think of as a preparation for
DNA synthesis for what's known
as the
S-phase where DNA synthesis
actually occurs.
And now, you're at 4N.
You've doubled the DNA content,
and there's G2 where it cleans
up from
S-phase, gets ready for
mitosis, and mitosis is when
you, then, separate
the daughter chromatids,
go back to 2N,
and then ultimately
the cell divides.
And we are back to 2N.
And when we
were talking about DNA
replication, I told you how
replicative DNA
polymerases test for
Watson-Crick shape,
and remember that little
movie I showed you where they
flipped the base pair into a
very
narrow slot in the protein,
and they check that it's there.
And they
said at that time,
that's why polymerases have a
problem when they
hit a lesion such as a thymine
dimer that we get if we go out
in the sun.
And then one of the recent
pieces of excitement in the DNA
repair field
that I work in,
was the discovery of a whole
class of translesion DNA
polymerases that have very
flexible, active sites and we
are able to copy
over a lesion.
Right at this point,
you will find in the literature
all
sorts of reviews about
polymerase switching,
where people are
envisioning the replicative
polymerase coming along.
It hits a
lesion, gets stuck.
It recruits one of these
translesion
polymerases that comes in,
copies of the lesion;
it switches back to the
replicative polymerase,
and then it goes.
And there are reviews like
that coming out in the
literature.
So, one of the genes that's
needed
for this sort of error prone
kind of translesion synthesis in
yeast and
in humans is a gene called
rev-1?.
You don't have to know this
for the exam,
this bit.
But if you knock out the
function of
that gene, the yeast aren't
mutated by UV or chemicals
anymore.
So, you
know it has an essential
function somehow in this process
of
translesion synthesis.
So, one of our big surprises
was I was trying
it.
We were trying to actually fish
out partners that might interact
with it cause we thought it
would be regulated.
And we were surprised.
The experiments revealed
something we hadn't expected.
We found out
that this protein that was
critical for mutagenesis was
extremely
strongly cell cycle regulated.
Well, given the reviews I've
told
you, or if somebody were
writing a textbook today,
this is what they
would tell you:
polymerase switching during
S-phase.
So you might have
thought it would be high and
S-phase, but it isn't.
We can
barely detect it during
S-phase.
But instead,
the rev-1 levels are at
least 50 times in the G2M
phase.
Actually, it goes right through
this
part of the cell cycle,
50 times what they are during
S-phase.
And so, there's a couple of
possibilities right now.
Either
these very tiny amounts that
are doing S-phase are what
everybody
thinks and current models would
predict: you're getting
polymerase
switching.
And it makes 50 fold more
during this phase for something
else.
If so, I don't know what that
is.
The other possibility is that
we have to rethink our model,
and that it isn't polymerase
switching
during replication.
Actually, the replication fork
just keeps
moving, and it leaves behind
little messes.
And when the cell is busy
starting to line up chromosomes,
and even
while it's pulling them apart,
that's when this translesion
synthesis stuff comes in,
and it cleans up the damage.
Now, I don't
know what the right answer is.
That was one of the things I
was talking
about yesterday morning.
But it's an example of how
something that you
guys can now hopefully at least
understand in principle is being
debated right now.
And the finding from my lab
changed
the way I'd been thinking about
it at least.
I can now see another
very real possibility.
So, just to move on,
so we are going back to
Mendel now, who did an awful
lot more than I told you.
A few of you
thought it was pretty
frustrating and it had all that.
But Mendel was
doing other things.
You already know what he could
do.
He knew how
to do crosses.
He knew how to count.
And he could think,
which
was really important.
And he's saw ratios instead of
just
numbers.
So it was another class of
experiments that he could do,
and
that was he could do a cross
where he looked at more than one
trait at
once.
And he didn't have all that
many options for things he could
do,
but he did what are known as
dihybrid crosses,
where he followed
two traits at once.
And I showed you some of the
traits
that he studied.
In fact, that picture I showed
you is actually a
cross that we can think of
right now.
He's got smooth,
and yellow,
wrinkled, and green,
and yellow, and you'll see them
in all four
combinations.
So, an example of the kind of
cross that Mendel carried
out, then, was he took smooth
yellow, which actually is the
dominant allele,
and both, which he learned from
his other crosses.
And he crossed it with wrinkled
green, which I'll represent as a
little s, little s,
little y, little y,
where he previously knew the
little s and little y alleles,
the wrinkled and green were
the recessive alleles.
And then, the F1 generation,
wouldn't be surprising to you
at this point,
I think, that they were
all smooth, yellow.
And, they all were Ss Yy.
And if you think about
the possible gametes you get
out of this, you could only get
a big S,
big Y out of this one,
and little s,
little y out of that one.
So if they came together,
it would have to be that.
So then, he
self-crossed the F1,
and what he got out of that was
the kind
of mixture of things that he
saw there.
He saw smooth yellow,
smooth green,
wrinkled yellow,
and wrinkled green.
In doing the same kind of
experiments that we talked about
before, he counted them,
he looked to see if he saw
characteristic
ratios.
He did.
The ratios he saw were 9:3:3:1.
So,
I think we know how his head
worked at this point.
He tried to figure
out if he could explain these
results by the kind of model
that he
was developing where hereditary
information came in,
in particles.
And he could.
But he had to make a critical
assumption.
And if you've just seen the
next square I'm going to draw,
without
realizing the assumption
underlies it,
then you've missed a great deal
of his thinking.
And that was that the two genes
assort, or the two
traits anyway,
because he didn't know they
were genes
yet, independently.
And the way we could see that
would
be to think about what were the
kind of gametes that you could
make from
those F1s.
So, we could get a big S and a
big Y from here,
or a big S
and a little y,
or a little s and a big Y,
or a little s
and a little y.
And, since this is selfing,
it's
the same thing.
So I won't fill this whole
thing in, but we get two
S's, two big Y's here.
Down here we'd have little s,
little y like
that.
I'll fill in a couple up here
where we've got big S,
big S, big Y,
and a little Y.
Here we have big S,
big S, but two
little Y's.
Here we'd have big S,
little s, big Y little y.
And over
here we'd have big S,
little S, two little y's.
So, if you were to make
out a table or a chart like
this that showed the phenotypes,
you'll find that all of these
look wild type,
we can see it here.
However, this one would be
smooth.
But it's got the two alleles.
So it
would be green.
This one would be smooth and
yellow.
And this, again,
would be smooth but green.
And down on the corner it is
the wrinkled
green.
And if you follow that out,
draw out the rest of that,
you'll
discover there the 9:3:3:1
ratios.
That was what Mendel observed
in all
of his experiments.
But he wasn't particularly
bothered
by it because he'd shown
particulate information.
The fact they
assorted randomly wasn't an
issue.
However, that was before people
knew
about the chromosomes,
which we spent quite a bit of
time talking
about the other day.
As I said, when people saw
those chromosomes
that gave rise to what's known
as the chromosomal theory
of inheritance.
And what was interesting about
chromosomal theory of
inheritance was that it
predicted a different
outcome depending on whether
the traits you were studying
were
encoded by genes on the same
chromosome or by genes on
different
chromosomes.
Now, as it happened,
what I think Mendel did was he
found
traits that were well behaved
and he could study.
And those all happened to be on
separate chromosomes.
So, his
results didn't disclose this
issue that was raised by the
discovery of
chromosomes.
The chromosomal theory of
inheritance gives,
as I said,
predicts different outcomes
depending whether things are on
the
same or different chromosomes.
So let's consider that by
taking the
F1.
So, say they are on separate
chromosomes.
And let's take the F1
from the previous cross over
here.
So, big S., little s,
big Y, little
y, and then we'll cross it with
the homozygous recessive parent.
That was a cross that I
mentioned the first lecture was
very
important.
It's important enough that it's
given a special name.
It's called a test across.
Well, here we are using it
here.
Well
what are the possible outcomes
that could come from this sort
of thing?
Well, I think the way you could
think about it most easily is,
what
kind of gametes or sex cells
could we get out of this?
Well, from here we could get a
big S and a big Y.
Or, we could get a big
S.
and the little y,
a little S and a big Y,
or a little S and a little
y.
So, we could get four different
types of sex cells.
The gametes we
can get out of this side,
there's only one type.
So, if we start
combining those,
I think you can see what the
outcome would be.
It's so simple.
We don't even need to draw out
the square.
If we had
big S, big Y over,
they're all going to be over.
Well actually,
I'll
draw up this way because I
think it's a little easier to
see.
So,
there would be four possible
things that would come out of
this test cross.
This would be the smooth and
yellow.
Here would be,
what have I done wrong here?
No, this is right.
This should be smooth and
green.
This would be wrinkled and
yellow.
And this would be wrinkled and
green.
And, do you see what the
ratio would be?
It would be 1:1:1:1 because we
have an equal probability
of making any of those.
And, I'm going to rearrange
these
because that way that it'll
help us think about it,
this is one of the
types that we've found in the
original cross.
That's a parental
phenotype, smooth and yellow.
It was one of the parents up
there.
This is the other one that
looks like one of the original
parents.
So, I can divide these into
parental or nonparental
phenotypes.
These are 1:1,
and then these others were ones
where the progeny differed
from the parent.
And they're all 1:1:1:1.
Now, that's what the
chromosomal theory of
inheritance would predict if
they were on
separate chromosomes.
That's what Mendel saw when he
was
doing his crosses.
What if they were on the same
chromosome?
So, we are going to have to go
back to the original
cross now to think this one
through.
So, what Mendel started with
was a
smooth, yellow parent.
So that was SYSY.
But because these
are on the same chromosome,
I'm going to depict them this
way so we
can see they're going to travel
as a unit.
So that was then crossed with
the wrinkled green,
which would be a little s,
little y in each case.
This should be F1.
In this case they will be all
smooth and yellow.
The recessive traits disappear,
but
this time they're only.
What the progeny will have,
they will have
gotten one of the possible
alleles from this one,
which would be the SY
on the same chromosome,
and one from the other parent,
the little s,
little y again on the same
chromosome and one from the
other
parent, the little s and y,
again, on the same chromosome.
So now if
you start to ask,
what will happen if I do a test
cross, you're going
to get a different outcome.
So here's the test cross in
this case.
So, we've got this F1.
It's smooth and yellow,
but it's actually at the
chromosomal level now.
It's like this,
and we're crossing it with the
homozygous recessive parent
that's now going to look like
that.
So if
you think through,
what kind of gametes could we
get out of this?
Well, there's only two
possibilities.
We could get this
one or this one.
And over here,
the kind of gametes
we could get,
there's only one type.
So, what are we going to get
out of
this cross?
What we'll end up getting is
big SY, over the little
sy, or little sy over the
little sy like that.
That's smooth and
yellow, wrinkled and green,
the ratio of these 1:1.
But you see the difference from
what we saw before?
These are the
parental phenotypes.
The chromosomal theory of
inheritance doesn't predict that
you
will get, or it predicts that
you will not get the nonparental
phenotypes.
So, if you wanted to
distinguish between these two
hypotheses, and figure out
where your genes were,
you'd do the
experiment.
And what happened when this was
done, again, what often
happens in science,
you think you've got it
straightened out.
You got
hypothesis A and hypothesis B,
and you do experiment planning
to do the
scientific method and show it.
And you get a result that isn't
what you
expected with either model.
And that's in fact what
happened
in this case.
And it led to the discovery of
genetic recombination.
And to show you actually the
experiments where
that was discovered,
I'm going to switch to another
widely used
genetic model,
which is the Drosophila
melanogaster,
or the
fruit fly, which you see in the
summer around rotting fruit.
Or if
you're in the biology building,
one is apt to land on your
sandwich
because there's just a few
stragglers that get out of the
Drosophila genetics labs.
But the one thing you can see
from
this is the eyes,
pretty cool.
It's got red.
The wild type is a red
eye, and the body's brown.
And, you can see the red eyes.
If you look
at a fruit fly carefully,
you'll be able to see,
the summer if you take
a look, you'll see that they
have red eyes.
So, they've been a very
useful model organism for
genetics partly because they
grow pretty fast
and they are easy to handle in
a lab.
And so, I'll introduce you to a
couple of features.
So, the wild
type you find in nature is a
brown body.
We'll call it a plus,
and it
has normal wings,
and which I'll refer to as
plus.
And some mutant
phenotypes that geneticists
have been able to find is a
black body
which I'll refer to as little
b.
And vestigial wings,
which I'll
refer to as VG.
So, these are fairly easy to
score.
They look
like little tiny wings.
It's fairly easy if you're
crossing Drosophila,
and looking at progeny to go
through and score,
what color are
their eyes?
And do they have ordinary wings
or little wings?
So, this is the kind of cross
that was carried out.
We are going to
switch now to an organism that
has male and female.
Up until now,
plants are both.
They make pollen,
and they have the eggs that are
going to develop into the seeds
once they're fertilized.
But, Drosophila
are more like us.
They come in males and females.
So, we're going
to have to specify which is
which.
And I think most of you are
probably
familiar with this terminology.
This is the symbol geneticists
use
for female.
And this is the one that is
used for male.
So, in this
case, let's set up exactly the
same kind of thing that we start
here.
We're going to cross a
homozygous parent versus a
homozygous recessive
parent.
That's just exactly the kind of
thing we have up here.
But
I'm going to do at this time
using Drosophila genetics speak.
And so, we'll be taking female
whose wild type for both traits,
we're
going to cross with a male
that's homozygous recessive for
both
traits.
This is the way Drosophila
geneticists tend to represent
this
kind of thing.
So it's exactly the same kind
of cross we got before.
And at this point,
what we get out of the F1,
it shouldn't
be news for you.
You can see genetically what
it's
going to be.
They'll have to get one allele
from here, one allele
from there.
So, by definition,
the only possibility that you
can get
out of this,
the F1s, will all have one
allele dominant,
and one
recessive allele just like up
there.
And this will be,
since the wild
type is the dominant allele,
this will be brown and normal,
and normal wings.
And then, at this point they
then
will set up a test cross,
exactly the same idea.
We're going to take
the F1.
And in this case,
we'll take a female whose got
this, and
we'll cross her with a male who
is homozygous recessive.
So that will be black over
black, and vestigial over
vestigial.
And
out of this,
there are four possibilities.
We can get parental
phenotypes.
So, there will be,
from that, black over,
if you look to the
various combinations of how
these things could go together,
you'll
find we can get vestigial plus.
Or, we can get black over
black, and
vestigial over vestigial.
For example,
this one, coming from those
two getting together,
and this one coming from this
one and this one
getting together.
So this is just exactly the
same kind of thing we've
done but done using Drosophila
traits.
And then, nonparental,
so now we get,
for example,
black over black,
and vestigial over plus,
black but normal wings,
or we could have black
over plus, vestigial over
vestigial, which would be a
brown body, but
with vestigial wings.
So, if we were trying to do
this
kind of cross,
we are doing this kind of
cross, and we are trying to
see what the outcome would be.
Mendel, every trait assorts
independently would predict the
1:1:1:1.
And the chromosomal theory
of inheritance would predict
we'd get 1:1 here,
and we wouldn't see
those at all.
Instead, what happened when
this experiment was
done where numbers that didn't
really fit.
This part works pretty well.
These are numbers from an
experiment of
this type.
So these are pretty close to
1:1.
That's OK.
That fits
with both of the models.
The surprise is over here where
there is
206 to 185.
So, these are in the ballpark
of 1:1.
But what you can
see is the result is not what
was predicted by the model.
This is the kind of thing I've
sort of been trying to tell you
through
the course.
It keeps happening in biology.
It's not a QED sort of
thing where you can work it out
by logic.
Very often, you do an
experiment, you get a result
that doesn't fit within your
current
framework.
And then you have to go back
and redo your thinking.
So
what was going on here,
as it turned out,
and it all got sorted out,
was
scientists had just discovered
genetic recombination.
And here is where,
what was going on.
So when we talked about Meiosis
I, and we had duplicated the
DNA, so we now had two
chromatids, and I
showed you the chiasma when it
was drying, it looked sort
of like this.
And, I said that you always saw
these physical attachments that
once the homologous pairs were
duplicated, they would always
be in contact.
And I said there was
actually a physical interaction
going on there.
Well what was going
on in there was an exchange,
a recombination event at the
DNA level
that's just exactly equivalent
to what was happening when I
showed you
the phage cross.
Remember, we had a phage cross,
and
if we got a recombination in
between the two genes,
then we could get
progeny that were a mixture of
the two traits.
So, if we were plus
plus, for example,
these are on the same
chromosome.
And the other one
is like this,
black, vestigial,
black, and vestigial.
If we get a genetic
recombination going on here
where these two
intersect and recombine in
between these two genes,
what you get out of
that, then, is this chromatid
is still the same.
It's got both wild
type alleles.
But in this case,
now, the black allele has moved
from
here to the tip of this one,
pairing it with that.
And the other chromatid over
here, the other homologous pair,
now has
the plus together with the
vestigial here and then here.
So, if you,
then, draw out the possible
gametes one will look like one
parent.
One
will look like the other
parent.
This one can give rise to a
nonparental phenotype in a test
cross.
And that one can give rise
to a nonparental phenotype in a
test cross.
And that's what's going on in
this experiment I've described.
But the
nice thing about this since
this sort of thing is happening
is one
can calculate,
then, a recombination frequency
in just the same way that
we calculated it when we were
doing phage cross.
And in this case,
it was the recombinants,
which in this context
I'm referring to the
nonparentals,
the recombinants over the total
of
the parental types and the
nonparental.
So in this case,
this would be 206 plus 185 over
965 plus 944 plus 206
plus 185.
And if I haven't blown the
arithmetic, that would be a
recombination frequency of 17%.
Now, we were back talking about
that
phage cross.
Remember, we did a pair of
crosses between gene one and
two, and between two and three,
and then we were trying to
figure out if
they were in the linear order,
how we could explain it.
And we finally worked out the
order by crossing allele one and
three.
And we made a little genetic
map that could show the order of
gene 1,
2, and 3, based on nothing more
than the recombination
frequency.
So,
that's exactly what people were
able to do by this kind of
measurement.
And that, then,
led to the generation of
chromosome maps.
This
is a publication from Science
in 1994.
This is before the human
genome was done.
And they were mapping a kind of
genetic marker
that we'll talk about when we
do restriction enzymes.
But they were
able to associate it with
banding patterns they had seen
on the chromosome.
This is the sort of thing that
cytologists saw,
and as scientists were working
this out, then they
were able to associate these
genetic maps of loci,
and begin to associate
them with the physical maps of
banding patterns in chromosomes.
Now we have the sort of
ultimate genetic map,
which is the sequence
of the human chromosomes.
So now we know exactly,
to the base pair,
how
far different genes are.
Part of the way that the human
genome was assembled from all
these little tiny fragments of
DNA that
were sequenced were taking
advantage of these kind of maps
that told the
scientists assembling all these
little fragments of DNA sequence
what order they had to be in,
what part of the chromosome
they were on,
and that kind of thing.
There is, this,
then, leads us,
though, to
other issues since I've now
started to talk about
chromosomes.
And one
more thing, let me just say
before I leave this.
So, from this kind of thing,
if the recombination frequency
is much less
than 50%, then they're on the
same chromosome.
And the word
geneticists use to describe
this is they say genes are
linked.
If the
recombination frequency is 50%,
then they are on different
chromosomes.
At this point,
it's just random assortment.
You go one way or
the other so you get a number
of 50% if you do this kind of
calculation.
And these are referred to as
unlinked.
And those of you
who are thinking about it can
probably imagine that there
might be
a problem, that if you had a
very long chromosome,
so the two genes
you are studying were very far
apart, you might get so many
recombination events in between
that it would begin to look,
the
recombination frequency might
come close to 50%.
And you would perhaps have a
difficult time in that genetic
cross
telling whether the genes are
really unlinked.
They were on separate
chromosomes,
or they were linked but very
far apart.
So this kind of
thing could be a little hard to
resolve that kind of situation.
But
there are other things you can
do to look at that.
So, the chromosomes
we've been talking about are
what are known as autosomes.
These are identical pairs.
But there's an exception.
And those are
the genes that are involved in
sex determination.
It's the chromosomes
that are involved in sex
determination.
These are known as
heterosomes.
And, they're on this picture
that I showed you where they
used this technique of
chromosome painting to show it.
You can see how all these
autosomes are in identical
pairs.
But this is
a male, obviously,
because there's the
Y-chromosome,
and there is an X.
If you're a female,
you'd have two copies of the X,
something I think
most of you know.
So, if we think about how this
works in humans,
females have two X's,
and males have an X and a Y.
In Drosophila,
the fruit fly,
it's the same thing.
Males have two X.
Females have two X's,
and males have an XY.
But there isn't anything
magic in nature about females
having two of the same,
and males having
one of each because in birds
where it's different enough they
use
different notation.
The females have one of each.
And
let me make sure I got my
notation right.
I think it's ZZ,
excuse me.
And the females have one of
each.
So, nature tends to use these
differences as far as sex
determination.
And this, then,
poses a new kind of problem.
And that is,
what would
happen if you were doing a
cross, and the allele that you
are studying
happened to be on a sex
chromosome instead of one of
these?
You might
guess that since females have
two of one and males have one of
each that
I would not give the results
that are predicted by what we've
talked
about so far.
And so, this led to the
discovery of what's
known as sex linkage.
And that's important.
And in fact,
as you'll see in a minute,
affects stuff that we are
familiar with in
our lives.
I want to just quickly
introduce you to this,
and show you
how it was discovered.
It was done by Thomas Morgan in
1910 actually,
this discovery.
What he was doing was he took a
white eyed male,
crossed it with a red eyed
female wild type,
and yet the expected
result that the F1s were all
red eye.
But then when he took the F1
female, which was red,
and crossed it with a
red eyed male,
you got something that was very
puzzling at the time.
The females were all red.
The males, half of them had red
eyes,
and half of them had white
eyes.
If you followed the logic up
until now,
where you try to work this out,
you would find that you
couldn't
generate this pattern by the
stuff that we've talked about
now.
So
once again, this led to the
need to create a new model,
something that
expanded our thinking.
So, the way the thinking went
was,
well, there must be something
to do with the sex of the fruit
fly in
this.
And so, here was the
hypothesis, and that was that
the
white eyed male had this
genotype.
They had an allele that caused
the
white eyeness.
But it was located on the X
chromosome so that the male
would have had a Y chromosome
paired with that.
And, the red eyed female used
in the first cross would have a
wild type
allele on both X chromosomes.
And so, if that were the model,
what's
going to happen to them when we
do this cross that we've
described
here?
Well, let's think it through.
So, we've got female
whose X plus.
We're crossing with the male
who's
got the X with the white allele
over the Y.
So, the females can either
be, they'll get an X plus XW,
and the males,
yeah, right.
The males are going to get,
they will get this allele for
Y.
So
now, if he takes us red eyed
female, that was the F1 from the
cross up
here, which will be this,
and crossed with a red eyed
male.
Now,
that means the male has to have
the good allele.
What are we going to get?
Well, for the females in this
cross, we've got
a couple of possibilities.
This one, we could get just the
wild type
female back,
or we could get this one
pairing with this one,
which
will give us this.
So, these are all red that fit.
But, the males,
then, if you see what happens,
they have to have,
each have to have a Y,
and then they can either get
this allele or that
allele.
If they get this allele,
they're red.
If this allele,
they're white.
If you stand back and look at
that, you will see that
is the outcome that was
observed.
Females were all red.
The males are
half red, half white.
Well, this is a characteristic
of,
this would be an X-linked
trait.
And I want to just point out
one
thing.
This female,
excuse me, wrong female.
This female here is
what's referred to as a
carrier.
She's got this allele that
causes a
white guy, but she's not
expressing it herself.
But she's able to transmit it
to her sons.
And when she has progeny,
on
average, half of her sons will
have the trait.
And now, X-linked
traits, there are a number of
them that we know about.
Some of you may
know hemophilia.
Queen Victoria was a carrier of
this gene causing
hemophilia, where there is a
problem with the clotting
mechanism.
And if
you get a cut,
then you can bleed a lot.
So, some of her sons had this.
A more common one,
which has to apply
to some people in this room,
is red-green color blindness.
If
you're a male,
you have a much higher
probability of being
colorblind because it's an
X-linked trait.
And I want to just close by
showing you how human
geneticists think about the sort
of thing.
And
we have to think about things
differently if we are doing
human
genetics because as most of you
know, I think all of us would be
very uncooperative subjects in
a kind of genetic cross that a
fruit
fly geneticist or most
geneticists would like to have
us
do, in which we'd be put in a
cage with a member of the other
sex and say,
mate.
That was your choice in life.
Well,
that would be a different kind
of existence for us all.
So, human
geneticists don't have that
luxury of having pure breeding
strains and
doing controlled crosses.
We all have very strong
feelings
about the kind of crosses that
we want to engage in.
And so, what
they have to do,
they have to make use with what
they find.
And they
use a couple of symbols here
that I'll just show you.
They look at
pedigrees, and then they look
for patterns.
And, they use a little
shorthand for doing this.
Males are squares,
which I don't know if
there's any symbolism to that
or not, but if they are affected
they
show it as a shaded square,
and unaffected as an open
symbol.
So, affected males are solid
squares.
Affected females are solid
circles.
So, let's take a look at the
sort of pedigree that human
geneticists might see.
And let's consider something.
Let's consider
red-green color blindness,
which is an X-linked trait.
So, let's take a
male, which there is probably
one in this room at least,
maybe
more, who have this.
So, since the colorblindness
trait
is on the X chromosome since
he's a male, the other pair will
be Y.
That means if you're a male and
you've got it,
you're going to
display the phenotypes.
So this is, George,
let's say, who is
colorblind.
They leave a lot of the romance
out of these things,
as
you'll see, who had progeny
with Mary.
Let's say, they got married
after they graduated from MIT.
It was very happy.
They had a, let's see,
son.
He had to get the Y from dad.
So, he had
to get a good allele from his
mother.
But they also had a
daughter, and she had to get
the color blindness allele on an
X
chromosome because the dad only
had one of them,
and then a
good one from her mom.
So at this point,
everybody's
normal.
But you'll notice,
this daughter has this trait of
being a
carrier because even though she
doesn't display the trait
herself,
she's got it in her genome.
So, let's say,
this son marries
a woman who doesn't have any
colorblindness allele.
So, if we have,
let's say, a daughter,
and a son, a daughter,
and
a son, this is not much
happening over on the part of
the pedigree.
Everybody would be normal.
Yeah, did I miss something?
Pardon?
Oh,
it's over Y.
Excuse me, yep,
I'm going too fast here.
Over Y, here
we go.
I don't need to introduce any
genetic abnormalities on top of
what we're already trying to do
here.
This is complicated enough.
OK, so what happens,
let's say then that the
daughter that married a
guy, and they had four
children.
I'm going to help us with the
genetics of it,
from the geneticist,
that sort of a perfect family
in
this case would be four kids
representing all four
possibilities.
And so, first off let's think
what would happen with the
daughters.
Well, the daughters could
either have the colorblindness
allele
paired with this one.
Or, they could get a wild type
allele with
this one.
So actually,
I'd better put this in.
So this is a daughter.
So this would be CB over plus,
or it could be plus over plus.
This one would,
again, be a carrier.
Now, with the sons,
they're both
going to get the Y since
they're male.
But there's a possibility of
either getting the good allele,
which means he'll be
unaffected.
But, if you get the other one,
he'll be affected.
Now, this would be sort of a
typical pedigree.
And you realize,
depending on the number of
kids, you might or might not see
this.
But
this, you're going to get to do
some more of these and to do
some other
traits.
But let me just sort of point
out, if you're a human
geneticist, what you would
recognize here,
the trait's more frequent in
males.
The frequency of color
blindness is about 8% on the X
chromosome.
So, if you're a female,
you've got to have two of them.
So
that means, you've got 0.64%
because you've got to get two
together.
It's a much smaller
probability.
The trait skips a generation,
We often say.
You see it here.
You see here.
But
you don't see it in between,
and that's because you have
this
carrier.
The affected males don't
transmit to their sons because
what
they give to their sons is the
Y.
So, they can't give them the
colorblindness thing.
And then, the heterozygous
females who are
carriers will transmit the
trait to their sons about half
the time.
And
that's a pattern that a human
geneticist would look for.
And
they'd say, ah-ha,
it must be an X-linked trait.
And you'll see in your problem
sets and recitation sections are
the
patterns.
OK, I'll see you on Friday.